It's rare to invite the same songwriter to a tea party twice
.
If I hadn't urged you to come out, your heart would have been shattered Hey,
why don't you listen to Zakimi's words of gratitude?
I
wonder if there's a way to rewrite the
restrictions It's a restriction that I'll forget about you if I get a lot out of
it As long as I have that, my heart might break
And my heart isn't the
only thing that
matters  I won't do such a shameless imitation I won't do
it, but I think you're a little cowardly On top of that, it's
my platform station,
but I forgot Wachau I still have to increase the words of someone who comes to mind  I can put it out,
but it's like a lie Thank you for making tea The witch next to me is a maiden